5 Kimchi is our country's fermented food when you look at it as a Korean kimchi, and when
you grow big, you are proud of our country, and to me, love was like that, but
I'm
Kim Myung-seong.
What I'm doing is making Danta Yangha fermented food continuously for 7 days.
In order to do this, I immediately
jumped in and started making kimchi and trying to put it properly,
and I realized
that there was something wrong with the
kimchi.
Kimchi is
the future for me because it's our children and yesterday and it's going to be the next generation
.
Kimchi expressed as masita is
really cool and reluctant to do housework
.  The
kimchi made by mixing these same
seasonings with the first management together and
aging it for more than 6 months with good aging is
the kimchi that I
made, and
the team that I can always
brag about to anyone.  I went to see people again,
asked about the experiences of the
parts, borrowed some wisdom from the parts, and in this way
, my kimchi as it is yesterday
came out.
I think that this is pride in our Korean food culture.